well you know first of all I want to
talk about like you did 10 years on
Hawaii Five-0 right so like that yep
I remember talking to you and going back
and forth Hawaii is by the way like five
six hour flight yeah
was that a good time in your life was it
one of those things where you're like
you you you liked it for a while and
then you were like sort of felt like you
were done because I kind of felt like
that in small villain but you had this
contract and like for me I had you know
I'd finish it out I had to do my work I
had to what was it like being on a show
for that long and no one like I've done
this I've said this we've done because
it's got to get redundant yeah man it
ups and downs like you know looking back
it was a great time I got to live in
Hawaii one of my daughters was raised in
Hawaii a little bit like there's
you know a lot of positives but there
are a lot of negatives too you know as
an actor if you do the same thing for 10
years it's like everybody's seen
everything you got you know it's like we
came up looking at actors who you'd see
maybe they'd do two movies a year you
know look at you know I mean someone
like Leonardo DiCaprio he does a movie
every couple years every time he comes
out the box with like this new thing
like you're seeing stuff you ain't never
seen if he did a show for 10 years it's
like we've seen everything you got you
know yeah so it's like
it's it's hard to not become schtick
like it's it's like oh he's doing shtick
you know it's like I'm doing a new show
now and I'm like God I wonder I'd like
it to be as far away as possible as that
other role but it it's still me like
yeah it's like you've seen my whole bag
of tricks yeah but there's an exception
uh and it's it's also a lot of luck
somebody like Brian Cranston who did
Malcolm in the Middle and you're like oh
he's a goofy guy and then you see him
and you're like well we transformed but
to your point he didn't show all that
stuff yeah but you know Hollywood I feel
like does not have a giant imagination
right like I did a procedural show for
10 years what's the first thing I get
offered another procedure yep so how
Brian Cranston was able to be Malcolm in
the Middle and then turn into uh uh
Breaking Bad Wayne no whatever what was
his name in Breaking Bad Walter White
Walter Walter White
um Wayne White Walter White uh Wayne you
know that's that's rare you know so he
he was able to I mean I remember I I
didn't watch Malcolm in the Middle uh
but I just remember people being the guy
from Malcolm in the Middle is doing this
it's like yeah man he's an actor like
he's meant to do this thing but studios
are the same way yeah the same way as
regular people which is yeah which is
why if you can write or you do have you
know if you can can't produce or you can
direct if you got as an actor like I
think that that's
the only way you're gonna tell them hey
I can do something else is if you do it
yourself yeah you know
um and um
yeah so anyway Hawaii five- there were
pluses and minuses I mean also
you know I didn't know what a procedural
television show was when I signed on to
do that I had no idea I I thought it was
going to be one thing and then it was
something else so
um but overall I look back at it as you
know a blessing and you know it was good
from you know I became I got married I
became a family man over there and I you
know I love to Surf I love Jiu Jitsu
like the culture over there fit me
perfectly but then at the same time I
miss home I miss New York I miss going
you know
doing movies you know I didn't do a
movie for 10 years
it's crazy because you were working that
was working nine months a year yeah
um
but uh but yeah man I I definitely look
back at it as uh something great but
there was parts of it that were shitty
you know